welcome back to drew's news
let me just say everyone in our audience
looks so stylish i really i mean gosh
you look good yeah meow i want your suit
i'm looking at you cute everyone came to
to show up and i'm seeing i'm picking up
what you're putting down
next up we love following a great
romance and right now we are so on the
pete davidson and kim kardashian love
train fascinated wait until you hear
this one okay remember when it all
started and kim was on snl and she
played oh ross oh hello
okay
she was aladdin and
she was jasmine and we know which one
you'd pick
um and they rode that cute magic carpet
together and they had that like kiss
that i think we all kind of were like
whoa whoa about there like because we
all kind of went oh my god they would be
so amazing together okay well now people
reports that for valentine's day pete
gave kim both of their costumes the lamp
and the rug so that they can remember
that magic moment forever just like you
know what a nice thing to do for someone
no it's so cute to go back i just
watched it to see how like they started
you know and then right after that she
showed him a whole new world and then it
all went from there
you know what i mean
and you were filling over aladdin yeah
well um rossi tell me about this next
story because it's a trend yeah and you
know we love the latest and greatest
trends here and it's time for a drew's
review
everything we review comes from you our
viewers and today's suggestion comes
from julia jones hi julia hi julia
thanks for this one all right today
we're going to try the fastest growing
sport in america it's something called
pickleball you heard of that has anyone
heard pickleball you guys know it
what is it
about pickleball because people are
going bananas yeah they're losing their
minds yeah they are relishing every
second of pickleball
stupid so stupid
no but it really it's right off it's a
big deal apparently
apparently pickleball is like ping pong
and tennis and badminton all hooked up
and had a baby okay and they called it
pickleball and it's so it's easy to set
up it takes less space than the tennis
court and it's easy on the old body and
guess what drew
we're gonna pick a ball it right now
come with me yeah come on oh cute
i'll do bread
this one
got a headband give me your ball hold my
ball
put a headband on that's cute
let's go
all right
we got our headband
um here's your paddle
come over here i go
right over here
so
here's how it works
[Applause]
the basic rules are simple the game goes
to 11 points and you're allowed one
bounce on each side so you get a point
only if you've served are you ready drew
oh okay easy right here first time
playing
oh no
hold on
let me be specific i suck at this game
you're supposed to hit it back to me
okay well
three two okay there you go
oh good drew good
oh good
listen i i can build you a brand i'm not
a good athlete
don't clap
don't clap for her
well
um i mean you know what here
what
there you go oh
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go
all right come on there you go good oh
yes oh yes okay
okay whoa
hey
still
so much better
well done now that's how you play it
thank you
[Music]
you